the former head of House Stark has
spilled the beans about his final
moments on Game of Thrones
even after seven more seasons of pain
and bloodshed the death of Eddard Stark
still stinks played by Sean Bean
Ned Stark was originally positioned as
the closest thing the expansive fantasy
series had to a main character making it
extra devastating and effective when he
met his maker at the end of the first
season
for those who don't exactly remember
what happened to Ned he falsely
confessed to treason after Robert
Baratheon died in a hunting accident
calculated by Cersei Lannister and
Cersei son Joffrey took the Iron Throne
Ned questioned Joffrey's claim to the
throne then Cersei had him locked up and
demanded he own up the treason though
Ned's daughter Sansa and Cersei both
asked Joffrey to reconsider the little
tyrant ordered Ned to death by beheading
anyway so long as I'm your king treason
shall never go unpunished
so Ilyn bring me his head just before
the blade came down the start patriarch
could be seen whispering a few words
with none of his last words being
inaudible and the books providing no
insights viewers have been left to
formulate their own guesses as to what
the former head of House Stark may have
said as he shuffled off this mortal coil
from the obvious possibility of the
series his favorite aphorism which
translates to all men must die others
have made more plot specific suggestions
like the idea that Ned was secretly
stating that Jon Snow wasn't his bastard
son but the child of his sister Lyanna
and Rhaegar Targaryen in an interview
with The Huffington Post actor Sean Bean
finally revealed Ned's last words they
weren't an important message with grand
implications for the plots nor a popular
catchphrase an actuality Ned said a
simple quiet prayer just before dying
being explains that he wanted to make
Ned's death seem as realistic as
possible in a series that features
dragons and men coming back to life and
a frosty villain who can reanimate
corpses he said I couldn't be too
specific because I don't know if
religion like that was around in those
days whatever they were I just thought
what would you do if this were really
happen you probably would pray you
probably would murmur some words and
keep it quiet you keep it to yourself
according to being he didn't set out to
give fans something to speculate on
saying he only spoke during the scene
because it felt right for the character
he added it's quite subtle and that many
people wouldn't pick it up it was an
interesting thing for me to do at that
point there's not much you can do really
you've got your head on a block that's
about the only thing you could do is
murmur the interview also confirmed that
being has indeed seen all of the online
talk regarding his many on-screen
demises including a rundown from Nerdist
that put the actors on-screen death
count just behind the oft murdered Kenny
from South Park according to the actor
he's pleased people are amused at the
unusual need she's carved out he said oh
I'll have to get some jobs some dying
jobs yeah I'm quite pleased with that I
don't mind being slightly behind a
cartoon character on the sort of bright
side Ned Stark was far from the last
person to face an untimely death
throughout Game of Thrones his run
battle after battle after battle saw
dozens of major characters fight the
dust where the final season including
some of the most shocking impactful
deaths of the entire series another much
beloved hero was killed in the exact
same manner as Ned a Swift sword chopped
to the neck ordered by a member of House
Lannister that character had but one
final word to say before dying that Kai
but Ned had a small list to peek out
with the way things are going on season
8 of Game of Thrones we just hope Ned's
prayer included a wish for everything to
turn out fine in Westeros check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]